[Music]
uh
did you draw these no oh
i didn't drew them
diddy you know actually these aren't
too bad how about that huh
a gorilla who draws
girl has that control
a gorilla who draws
now that's something oh boy daddy told
you i've been from john look
the press is gonna eat this up a gorilla
who can actually draw on that that's
that's like
that's a game changer
[Music]
okay all we have to do is make it across
and we're finally free
[Music]
well i'll just cross the road then why
would you cross the road henrietta
to get to the other side
oh boy
[Music]
are we done yeah i'm done
hello mr beetle
[Music]
hmm what is it a flying cow
no is it a hand no hands are so tough to
get right
really is it tennessee no kansas oh boy
is that me
what did you draw a picture of me no i
know it's a burrito no it's not a
burrito
don't tell me don't tell me don't tell
me it's a lonely haystack
on a late summer day
it's a beetle oh a beetle huh
[Music]
welcome to your new home
let's give him a great show okay i won
and only
why do they want an angry gorilla anyway
you're a silverback
he terrified humans oh
you're not terrifying
who's that my sister who's your sister
now
i don't remember memories never leave us
they just get out of reach whoa
did you draw all these a gorilla who
draws
what is it don't tell me don't tell me
it's a lonely haystack
on a late summer day
it's a beetle can you tell me a story
once there was a baby elephant who was
smart
and brave and she needed to live in the
wild where she could be free
[Music]
does the baby elephant get to be free
[Music]
this painting is clearly a sign he wants
to be free
what about mac he's taking care of me my
whole life
we're family we're in this together
[Music]
i'll just cross the road then why would
you cross the road
to get to the other side
welcome to your new home you want to
hear a story oh i love stories
the movie but one and only ivan is based
on a book
that is based on real life events for
one
and only ivan
there really was a very special gorilla
called ivan and he really knew how to
draw
whoa did you draw these a gorilla who
draws
ivan is played by the brilliant sam
rockwell can you tell what this is uh
a cheeto it's a key danny devito is
playing bob
now we're talking there's so many people
enjoy the show
let me add him you've got to love him
and also shaka khan
so the greatest casting ever
why do they want an angry gorilla anyway
you're a silverback he terrifies humans
you're not terrifying it's a beautiful
story
they're really a family trying to work
together to get a second chance
the wild yeah that's where we belong
what i loved about the story was that
you get to experience
an incredible journey with these animals
the story is really about learning that
it's never too late
to find out who you really are we're in
this together
we're family it's really nice to be a
part of something that you feel has
something really good to say
rated pg streaming august 21st on disney
[Music]
plus
[Music]
you